today we would like to introduce a topic
about which we're going to film a number
of episodes that being what is commonly
referred to as the Valley of the Kings
on the west bank of ancient Thebes
modern Luxor and the ancient Egyptians
called it "set Maat" the place of truth
now truth is a convenient translation
for maat but it's not the whole concept
maat is really morality justice cosmic
order and because the King was charged
with maintaining Maat
that's one of the main purposes of
pharaonic kingship in ancient Egypt it's
appropriate that the King's final
resting place would be called the place
of maat of truth so maat is essentially
the opposite of what the Egyptians call
isefet so maat is order isefet is
disorder but together they mean you have
an ordered world so everything for the
Egyptians consists of balanced pairs the
Valley of the Kings as we call it
becomes the burial place for really all
but one of the major kings of the new
kingdom beginning with the reign of King
hatshepsut mm-hmm
so hatshepsut when she is Queen has a
queenly tomb that was actually cleared
and recorded by Howard Carter Wow before
Tutankhamun in one
of the southern wadis of the great even
massive of the great Theban Hills in
which the necropolis of ancient Thebes
are located and to define Wadi what is
an Arabic term that refers to a dry
canyon and it's commonly used in
Egyptology so it's a good word to know
dry watercourses anything from one
Arroyo to a massive Canyon of some sort
so the Valley of the Kings is really a
large Wadi with a number of Forks to it
located just behind the area in the
western hills known as Deir el-Bahri to
examine a bit more
the Kings we're gonna pull out a map and
show you how that wadi interrelates to
some of the other geographical features
on the West Bank of Thebes when we
think about the monuments of modern-day
Luxor or ancient Thebes we think about
the big temples on the east bank Karnak
and Luxor and then the mortuary temples
on the west bank, Deir el-Bahri, Medinet Habu
the Ramesseum and the Valley of the
Kings is behind the cliffs of Deir el-
Bahri an interrelationship is
not exactly obvious so so here's the
temple of hatshepsut at Deir el-Bahri and
as the crow flies
the tomb of hatshepsut is very close but
if you go between the two points today
you have to go out of Deir el-Bahri, a
round Dra abu Naga and back in to the
road that takes us into the Valley of
the Kings most of the tombs are in this
main part of the body and this
juxtaposition is very interesting the
tomb of Tutankhamen kV 62 and the
numbers increase as more tombs are found
the tomb of Ramses the 6th which began
as the tomb of Ramses the 5th is KV
9 Kings Valley 9 and the reason why
fundamentally Tutankhamun's tomb was
found virtually intact is because when
Ramses the 6th excavated his own tomb
the material that was excavated went on
top of the tomb of Tutankhamun obscuring
it both from ancient tomb robbers those
that were sent out by the pharaonic
administration at the end of the New
Kingdom as well as anyone in more recent
times there's been some speculation that
tell us the first might have begun the
tomb that hatshepsut completes mm-hmm
but what we do know for certain is that
hatshepsut incorporated the burial of
her father Thutmose the first in her to
in the Valley of the Kings he is later
removed by Thutmose the third for whom
hatshepsut originally is regent and
reburied in another - so there is a tomb
in the Valley of the Kings that was only
for - almost the third but on the basis
of the history of his burial and
reburial and based on the architecture
of the tomb it's fairly clear that the
tomb that is often labeled as tomb of
Thutmose the first in the Valley of the
Kings was actually excavated for Thutmose
the first by Thutmose the third
complicated history we can go into this we
can go into this leader in much greater
detail but this juxtaposition of a tomb
in the Valley of the Kings and the
mortuary temple of Deir el-Bahri brings up a
really important point about ancient
Egyptian tombs in general and that's
that all tombs have a private and a
public component so the public component
the tomb Chapel is where you'd bring
offerings or speak invocation offerings
such as a thousand of bread a thousand
of beer thousand of fowl and a thousand
of beef because those are really the
four things you don't want to do without
in ancient Egypt so from from
very early on even apparently from the
first dynasty for the first dynasty
rulers we seem to have this group of
burial place and burial monument along
with some sort of a ritual center that's
located a little bit closer to the
cultivation closer to the Nile Valley
where people come for celebrations
that's really cool to see it going back
that far this is what's really
interesting because one of the books
we'll be talking about later in later
episodes we don't have time for that now
is it's time for it now well I think
it's going to take a lot more than 10
years we just introduced it so we call
the book of Amduat or Imy-duat that
which is in the netherworld sometimes
it's written as though it means he who
is in the netherworld the ancient
Egyptian original name for it seems to
be the book of the hidden chamber and in
the fourth and the fifth hours of that
composition it's one of the two
compositions along with book of gates
that emphasize the 12 hours of the night
as major divisions in the book of Amduat
in the
fourth and the fifth hours of the night
we see a series of descending corridors
and passageways that lead down to an
oval very similar to what we find in the
New Kingdom royal tombs in the Valley of
the Kings and this in the fourth and
fifth hours of Amduat is called Rosetau
the place of hauling and the
place of hauling interestingly first
comes up as the name for the Giza
necropolis so what we see in Egypt is a
really interesting interdependence of
actual architecture on perhaps religious
concepts and even religious tax and
illustrations and then those very text
and illustrations made themselves come
back and influenced architecture in some
way so we have descending passages and
corridors and chambers and pyramid
architecture earlier and certainly in
the New Kingdom royal tombs we walk
through an architectural realization dug
into the mountainside of realization of
this Rosetau this descending series of
corridors and passageways what we call
the underworld or the netherworld in
ancient Egyptian is the Duat so it's
spelled up with a star hieroglyph
followed by a T and often a
determinative that is the same
designation as a building what we would
call the "per" sign or that house
determinative and sometimes the star is in a
circle yes which is really significant
because the circular form of the burial
chamber the oval form of the burial
chamber is also the oval form of the
sarcophagus and interestingly that oval
form seems to be related to a snake's
egg as well as a womb so you go back to
this moment in the netherworld where the
Sun God descends this is all describing
his journey through the 12 hours of the
night and he descends into the very
lowest hours into the fourth and fifth
and sixth hour of the night and
he joins together with the waters of
Nun these chaotic waters that enable
the sun-god to be reborn and within
these chaotic waters is this circuiting
the serpent's egg is referred to as the
was the chamber of Sokar the egg or
the Oval of Sokar and the chamber of Sokar
that's down in the bowels of the
netherworld where the ordered world the
created world comes back into contact
with these chaotic waters this abysmal
substance called Nun that represents
the oneness out of which creation is a
separation into an infinite number of
balanced pairs when you walk into a
royal tomb of the New Kingdom you are
walking into a model of the first half
of the night journey of the Sun and what
happens after the middle of the night
happens in this realm beyond what we can
experience it happens in some parallel
extension of the royal tomb out beyond
this existence and what happens in the
egg of sokar is that the king descends
into the sarcophagus which is a model of
the egg of sokar where these chaotic
waters that are destructive for order
and life but that represent the
potentiality for rebirth for the dead
the sun-god goes back into those waters
turned in the nether world books youth
flesh the corpse of the Sun and is
reborn so the King would go down into an
oval into an oval sarcophagus similar to
this late 18th century Chinese export
for the American market tureen here and
the king would be reborn so we did show
- Tutankhamun Tut lives in the slanting pines tureen
we've never got to use him didactically
before perfect moment